[Música]
es momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en france24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
en esta ocasión iniciamos con las nuevas
variantes del cobi 19 que han causado
alarma entre la población y la comunidad
médica porque aún faltan muchos datos
por conocerse y los científicos están
investigando si podrían generar re
contagios masivos de la enfermedad en
sudáfrica un estudio del laboratorio
novavax indica que un 2% de las personas
que ya se habían contagiado con una
versión anterior volvieron a ser
positivos para el virus con una nueva
variante casos similares se han
registrado en brásil con la llamada
variante brasileña
parece que un re contagio es posible no
creo que entendamos por qué y por qué la
inmunidad no se ha desarrollado tras un
contagio natural parece que ocurre en
una minoría de las personas
parece que la vasta mayoría de las
personas que se contagian desarrollan
una buena cantidad de anticuerpos pero
no todas con el vaso medio lleno de la
historia es que estas variantes parecen
afectar sólo parcialmente e incluso en
estos estudios estamos viendo que aunque
hay evidencia de reinfección las tasas
de síntomas y de enfermedad severa por
re contagio son prácticamente
inexistentes
en eeuu un estudio realizado en el
centro médico mount sinaí de nueva york
encontró que el 10 por ciento de los
reclutas de la marina que contaban con
evidencia científica de haberse
contagiado antes del proceso y que
dieron negativo tres veces antes de
comenzar el entrenamiento volvieron a
contagiarse posteriormente cabe aclarar
que esto ocurrió antes de que las nuevas
variantes comenzaran a extenderse por
ello los científicos alertan que el re
contagio con la variante original del
virus también es posible y un contagio
previo no dará libertad de que no habrá
un re contagio
y las tasas de contagio son
considerablemente más que una ocurrencia
anecdótica
continuamos hablando de kobe 19 pero
ahora vamos a reino unido porque otro
estudio esta vez realizado por el juke
el bayo bank indica que en la gran parte
de la población las defensas tras el
contagio duran seis meses en el cuerpo
los responsables estudiaron las muestras
sanguíneas de más de 20.000
participantes que se recuperaron del
virus y encontraron que el 99 por ciento
de ellos mantuvo el nivel de anticuerpos
durante tres meses y el 88% durante seis
meses
y esto muestra que ya sea que se haya
contagiado con el virus o tal vez
después de la vacunación
una vez que produjo anticuerpos estos
duran un periodo de tiempo si tomamos
esos resultados en contexto con otros
estudios que han analizado la
probabilidad de reinfección que se ha
demostrado es muy baja durante el
periodo en que hay anticuerpos los dos
hallazgos parecen sugerir que una vez
que se ha tenido la enfermedad es
probable que se esté protegido durante
al menos seis meses
los científicos son sumamente cautos al
indicar que la inmunidad aunque existe
en una gran parte de la población no
está garantizada para todos y aún no se
sabe cuáles son exactamente los factores
que hacen que una persona no se vuelva a
contagiar ya sea con la variante
original o con otras por eso hacen
hincapié en que los recuperados
continúen usando tapabocas lavándose las
manos y manteniendo la distancia como el
resto de las personas
vamos ahora a españa' puntualmente a la
universidad de alicante el instituto de
ingeniería de procesos químicos
desarrolló un sistema de suministro
individual del aire limpio en espacios
cerrados y de uso común que según sus
responsables minimiza drásticamente el
riesgo de contagio de kobe o de otros
patógenos que se transmitan por vía
aérea se trata de un sistema colectivo
de suministro de aire de uso individual
es un sistema muy sencillo de este modo
se consigue que en todo momento los
usuarios estén únicamente conectados con
un aire desinfectado sin la posibilidad
de entrar en contacto con los aerosoles
que puedan emitir otros usuarios que
estén en ese recinto el mecanismo
consiste en un sistema que recoge el
aire y lo impulsa para que pase por dos
filtros que eliminan los virus y las
partículas que puedan estar presentes en
ese aire para mayor seguridad se pasa a
través de una cámara especializada
posteriormente el aire se canaliza y se
distribuye a los puertos a los que se
conectan las más
esos puertos cuentan con dos tubos uno
que pasa el aire desinfectado y el otro
que absorbe el aire que expulsan las
personas al expirar este también se
desinfecta y luego se envía al exterior
las ventajas del sistema pues son
evidentes ya que permitiría utilizar el
aforo de todos los recintos en donde se
instalará como pueden ser aulas teatros
cines medios de transporte vagones de
tren autobús etcétera el objetivo de
esta presentación es conseguir el
interés de alguna empresa que pueda
implantar estos dispositivos y estamos
convencidos de que es un sistema muy
eficaz para combatir la pandemia y
reducir el riesgo de contagio vamos
ahora japón porque la compañía nec corp
creó un sistema de reconocimiento facial
que permite identificar a una persona
aunque porte tapabocas los responsables
aseguran que la precisión es del 99,9
por ciento y el reconocimiento toma
menos de un segundo
nuestro sistema analiza las partes que
no están cubiertas con una máscara como
las esquinas de los ojos y las arrugas a
su alrededor nos enfocamos
específicamente en esas partes y
verificamos las caras dado que las
mascarillas se han utilizado ampliamente
entre quienes padecen fiebre del heno o
quienes quieren protegerse de la gripe
ha habido solicitudes para inventar un
sistema que pudiera verificar a las
personas incluso cuando lleven tapabocas
así es cómo comenzamos a hacer el
sistema el brote de la pandemia de
coronavirus nos instó a acelerar nuestro
proceso de producción y logramos lanzar
nuestro producto con una alta tasa de
precisión así llegamos al final de este
espacio pero recuerden que pueden
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom continúen
con nosotros estos france24
[Música]